- When I came to the TL,
you know, I'm an artist
and one of the projects I do is under,
it's under a pseudonym
and the first person that I
met that asked me my name,
I blurted it out.
I'm like now or never
so I said, Rogan.
Using a different name,
it creates this different
version of yourself.
And you're still you,
but I like that.
So it's like a different,
and so I have like a
slightly different identity.
- [Mark] Rogan it is.
(laughs)
- [Rogan] It can go either way.
I guess we'll just play it by ear.
- [Mark] Okay. So Rogan
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm from California.
I was born on Oahu
and my family moved to
Daly City when I was five
and we moved to
Fresno
at the end of sixth grade when I was 11.
And from Fresno,
I lived in Fresno until I was 25
and then that's when I
started moving around.
I went to Los Angeles and from Los Angeles
I moved to Colorado after meeting my ex
at a tattoo convention that
we were both working at.
And
then we got an RV and traveled
around the country for three
and a half years in an RV
and we came to San
Francisco the first time
and I just,
I fell in love with the city.
It's amazing here.
And I made it a point to come back.
We had this Epic trip
that we needed to take
to rescue our friend,
we thought we were gonna rescue our friend
from rehab in Florida. (laughs)
And it was a year,
took a year to come back to the city
and I've been here since then.
That was quite a while ago now.
- [Mark] So how was your childhood?
- Mh?
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- My childhood?
It was interesting.
I mean, everyone has, you know.
It was rough in some ways,
both of my parents were drinkers
and
my mother worked in the evening
and my dad
worked during the day
and so there was a lot
of time that I spent
just kind of on my own.
I really spent most of my
time as a kid on my own.
I had a best friend
and their family lived right
across the street from us.
But other than that,
I was kind of a loner.
And my dad was,
I said he was an alcoholic
and he was also physically abusive.
But looking back on it now,
I mean, I've long since forgiven
him before he passed away.
He was really the only
person that truly got me.
But I guess,
you realize your parents are just people
and I don't know how else really
he would have dealt with me.
(laughs) It's not right but,
I was a really precocious
child to say the least
and very persuasive and
wild.
I'm five and seven years
older than my brothers
So I was an only child
for a period of time
so I was spoiled and
the center of attention,
at least when I was really small.
When we lived in Daly City,
as a kid, you don't,
a lot of kids I guess don't really know
what your financial situation is.
You don't have any concept of money
and compared to different
levels of poverty that exist,
I can't say that we were that stricken,
but when we were,
my grandparents supported us.
And when my parents split up,
I was 14 and surprisingly,
my brothers, not for them,
but we all went and lived with my dad
who stayed in an apartment as
close as he could to my mom
as possible that he could not afford
and we were just completely destitute.
A friend of mine had a
job at Jack in the Box
and that was how we ate,
which was kind of awesome to
have those things
that you don't really
think about at the time,
but it was rough.
It was rough.
- [Mark] When did drug use start for you?
- I started using hardcore
drugs when I was, well, 14.
And once I started that,
that was it.
I actually wanted to be a
junkie since I was a little kid.
- [Mark] Really?
- It sounds really weird
but there was something
kind of like romantic
about it to me.
Mysterious.
And
I read a lot.
A lot.
And once I read
Jack Kerouac, that was it.
It was over.
And I read
"Big Sur" which definitely inspired me,
but one of his lesser known
books it's called "Tristessa"
and it was about this Mexican junkie whore
that he was in love with
and she just sounds so
wild and mysterious and untamed
and I wanted to,
I wanted to be her and
I also wanted to be him
in love with her.
Just the whole,
the whole package.
I was really enamored of it all
and I have to say that I
think I've experienced it now.
I use heroin and I've
done heroin now for so long.
I think that it's like a relationship.
Yeah, it's...
I can't imagine the,
I can't, I really can't imagine
parting ways permanently
but I take a break every once in a while
and
I have,
I loathe to admit it
but I did stop for a year and a half once
and I actually was happy. (laughs)
But it is what it is.
I am not
unhappy.
I make my own misery,
but if I look at my life
I have to say that
I've had exactly the life I wanted.
As rough as sometimes have been,
it's really exciting
and for as much torture
as I put myself through,
I realized, actually just last night,
how little stress I have in my life.
I'm so grateful for that and so just...
Money is awesome
and I feel that this
is gonna be my my year,
not to say that I haven't had it
and gone through plenty of it,
but I just have never really
given a shit about it.
Thank God. I always say,
I can be rented but I can't be bought.
We were watching some reality show
and people, wealthy people
and all their problems
and their stresses and I thought,
"God, thank God, I don't
care about any of that."
And we're so lucky.
It takes so little.
Just hang out in our hotel
room or wherever it is.
At one point we rented a
walk-in closet for $20 a day
in this really cool house in Russian Hill
and we were happy with that.
- [Mark] So you're living
in the Tenderloin now?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Mark] You're living on the street?
- No, no.
I've been doing the hotel
circuit of the Tenderloin
for years now, since I came here,
and I'm over it.
Now, I'm over it.
I mean, it's exciting,
but now it's not exciting anymore.
Moving constantly, having to move around
and I'm ready now to do something else.
I think I've found some
place in North Beach.
A big warehouse.
- [Mark] How have you
been supporting yourself?
- It varies.
I have been,
I have been a prostitute
in some fashion or other,
basically my entire life
and I'm not really into it anymore.
Not to say that,
I mean, not that I shun the idea.
Definitely, it's not the fun that it was,
when I first came here,
it was like Shangri-La
and a lot of women,
all the women I know kind
of had the same goal.
It's empowering to find
yourself and be sexy
and be somewhere where
everyone accepts that
and it's not something
that you're judged for
and it's something that people assume
about you, and correctly, and it's cool,
but
I just,
I don't smoke crack anymore
and that changes it, that changes things.
So,
I dabble in other,
if there's a hustle and
there's some money in it,
I'm into it.
- [Mark] Did you find the line
that you are willing
to cross to make money
has changed over the years?
- Yeah. Over the years
I've grown a conscience
or I should say that it's matured
and I don't want to,
I don't wanna be greedy
and I don't wanna take
anything from anybody.
I don't want anybody to,
just having it,
not to say that I'm an angel
and I'll probably be a
shoplifter until the day I die
just because,
but to wreck someone's life,
to take their life savings
and they have no recourse for that,
that's just not something
that I've ever been into.
- [Mark] So your moral compass
is changing for the better?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] As you age.
- Yeah. I actually,
I think about things now.
I didn't use to definitely.
But
my moral compass has,
it's got direction now.
- [Mark] Do you have friends?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
I find it near to impossible to
maintain communication
with my oldest friends.
I have friends that are not
from this version of my life.
Just like it is with my immediate family.
What is there to say?
Yeah, I'm doing this still.
There's a certain amount of
shame that comes with that
and I've got to get over it
because it's really just me.
I'm really blessed in
that the people I've known
for a really long time
have always accepted me
and picked up right where we left off
and I think the only person
that's judging me is me
but that's for the better,
the best, as well.
I mean, I need to look at myself.
I've got to do something with myself.
And it seems like everything's kind of,
it's coming to a head and I feel good.
I feel good about the direction I'm going
and I don't feel like
it's the last chance.
I just feel like it's the time.
It's the chance.
- [Mark] So you're more
hopeful now than you've been
in the past?
- Yeah. Definitely.
I feel finally that I have
not just a direction,
but a vision, you know?
I can kind of see it coming together
and I can,
I've found my self worth in there
in that mix where before I doubted myself
and I guess my
big deal is
one day I would finally find some success
and everyone at the party would stop
and you'd hear all the glasses clink
and somebody would say,
"What is she doing here?
She's an imposter, kick her out."
So I don't feel that way anymore.
I don't feel that way anymore.
- [Mark] Did you find yourself
getting depressed sometimes or?
- Oh yeah. I'm really manic.
I guess, I think that I'm what you-
- [Mark] I mean, living on the street,
it would be hard not to, right?
- Well, like I said,
I'm not living on the street.
- [Mark] (indistinct)
- But then again,
that could be less stressful than...
- [Mark] But it sounds
like you're scrambling
for a place to live from
week to week, right?
- Oh God, yeah.
And now this,
like since the coronavirus,
this is a blessing and it's
at the,
I don't wanna say at the expense
of so many other people
'cause it's definitely
not been a blessing to,
millions of people struggling
and losing loved ones
and
working nonstop and questions and no job,
and so there's that,
but for me, it's been a break
and it's been much more affordable.
I mean, sometimes the
hotels are only $35 a day
and as you know,
San Francisco is the most expensive city
to live in.
I paid $150 a day for a long time
just to stay at the travel lodge.
So this is a break, definitely
and it couldn't have come at a better time
because I'm just,
it's different now.
The scene has changed slowly.
I don't wanna,
I can't stand outside.
I'm not waiting to like hustle a date
and for so many reasons.
- [Mark] Yeah. Have
you had bad experiences
both working as a prostitute
or living on the street or
just hanging out in Tenderloin?
- You know I've been
really lucky my whole life.
Really only one
thing has ever happened to me
that that was really scary,
dangerous, horrifying
but still I wasn't hurt.
I'm really lucky
and I have this,
I just believe fundamentally
that nothing truly bad
will ever happen to me
and that's really important.
That belief makes it my reality.
But nothing has happened to me
in the Tenderloin other than,
shit I put myself through.
Thank God.
Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have kids?
- No.
- [Mark] No kids?
You've been married?
- I have been married,
yes. A long time ago.
A couple of lifetimes.
- [Mark] Do you think the environment
you grew up in as a child
somehow led you down this path?
- Well, I mean, as far as,
I mean, anyone, I think your childhood
definitely, it shapes you,
but I don't blame
my childhood.
I don't look back at
my childhood with any,
there's no anger really or resentment.
It's been my independent choice
and it wasn't until I came to the city
that I ever even looked
back at my teenage years
and relished in how cool that was
because it was a great
source of shame for me.
I'm from Fresno and
everybody knew about me
and some people even saw
and it never struck me what
they might actually be thinking.
I was just like, "Oh my God, this is what,
everyone must think I'm so
disgusting, this pariah."
And that really wasn't the case
but
it was really cool to
have no parents, no curfew
and I had this rocking girlfriend
and we were idiots and we were teenagers
so we're still kids but getting to,
we have all this money
and smoking crack and
staying in hotel rooms
and it was amazing.
It was a blast.
It was truly a blast
and I have met such amazing
people over the years
and had so many weird experiences.
Not my entire life has just been
focused on the streets.
I mean, I've had many different phases
and
I definitely think,
I know I'm an adrenaline junkie
and I'm definitely, I'm some
kind of, I'm a little bit
of a sexual degenerate.
I think a lot of us out here
are maybe the term sex addicts
but
I've experienced some weird things
and cool things and-
- [Mark] What's the craziest
thing you've come across?
Gotten into?
- Like on a date or?
- [Mark] Yeah, sure.
- I don't really have,
I mean, I never think of
my stories as that weird.
I have met some weird people though.
There was this guy that
used to pay me to put an M&M
(indistinct) talk.
That's not even that weird.
I'm just going to have to...
There's the whole,
there's people that one
paid to eat your shit
and I prefer to say a brown,
a brown shower.
And a golden shower, first of all,
is not exactly what one might thInk.
I mean, it's extremely intimate,
you're not just pissing on stuff
which can be artful and cool
but it can also be really
creepy and intimate
and again, I use the word intimate,
but there was a guy he was,
I met him at (indistinct)
which was amazing.
Once I found that it had
website and everything,
I met so many cool people through that.
This guy though, he kinda,
first it was just about a date
and then he revealed to me
that he wanted to do a golden shower
and I knew that this was gonna be,
I was really gonna be in for something.
So I'm like steeling myself for it
and then somehow we end up
on this topic and he
felt comfortable with me.
So he said he wanted to do a brown
and
I was like, okay.
I mean I wanna know about it.
Like what drives someone
to want to do this?
So at first I talked to Jersey about it.
I'm like, what do you think?
And he's like, "I'm right outside.
I support you. Go for it."
I told him that I would do it
under the condition that he
let me interview him first
and record it.
So I do have a recorded interview of this
and no insight after the interview,
I still don't know more
than I did when I started.
It was just like,
"So what made you wanna
be a human toilet?"
It was by far, like hands down,
the most disturbing,
unsettling, experience
I've ever had.
- [Mark] What was his answer
to that question?
Like why he was into it?
- He told me how,
see, there was some,
there's a story about his little sister
and seeing her,
seeing her pee
and something that he
wasn't supposed to see.
It was this naughty thing.
I think that he's leaving.
I don't know if he is, I can't,
I don't wanna assume that
there's some type of abuse
that's involved because I
certainly don't wanna judge
anyone for for what they do
'cause I just don't understand.
It was never clear to me.
It started out as he met this woman
and they started,
it just happened one time.
She peed
while he was going down on her
and I get all that,
I can wrap my head around it,
and they had a very,
he was the Sub and she was the Dom.
How it turned into shit,
I still don't really know.
One of the most disturbing
things is there's,
there's a button, okay?
This person has total control over you
and it's so psychologically,
you go to a very different place
than you think you're going to
'cause it's not all of,
it's not about them being dominated.
It's almost like you are the one
because they can make you start
and stop what this button
and
there's gagging
and it's all these thoughts
going through your mind.
Like, how could someone be doing this?
How could I be doing this?
And it is not
that's not the dollar
amount that you would think
that they leave.
It's just everything about it is,
yeah, it was.
And then he wanted me,
towards the end,
he wanted me to blow him,
like at the end of it.
And I was, so I just wanted to hit him.
Like, are you fucking kidding me?
Like, even if I was,
even if you weren't eating my shit,
psychologically, I can't go there now.
Like, what?
Oh, what kind of piece of shit is this?
That really upset me
and so I did not (laughs) oblige him.
Somewhere the recording of
the whole thing I still have.
I've never listened to it again.
I obviously at the beginning,
the interview part,
but,
(groans) so, so strange.
When I was in junior high,
me and (indistinct) would walk home
after school and there was
this guy in this red Scirocco
that would drive really slowly
and he was kind of following next to us
and I knew what he was doing.
He was jerking off in the car
to these two preteen girls.
So one day we tell him,
"Look if you don't give us some money,
we're gonna tell on you."
So he gave us $5 each, which was awesome.
And then we would just go and like
spend that money on candy or whatever.
And I knew this guy for years after that,
like off and on throughout the years
and it escalated.
There were two other things that happened.
There was the foot thing
and then there was also
once I went with him
to a carwash and it was,
you know the industrial vacuum cleaner
that doesn't really suck the (indistinct),
I had to hold the hose.
He was getting off like that.
And I was like ew.
And also, ow.
But he wanted a woman to step
on his face with their bare
foot as dirty as possible.
And that was his deal.
And only one girl though
because $10 was all he
was gonna pay for it
and I have discovered
throughout my trials in life,
$10 is all anyone ever paid for that.
But I asked him like,
what is it that,
why do you want to be
demeaned in this way?
Tell me about it.
And he was like,
well, it's not me.
I'm getting what I want.
He had a foot fetish.
He said that part of his thrill was
getting somebody to
compromise their own values
for such a nominal amount of money.
- [Mark] That's interesting.
- Yeah. It blew my mind.
And that's what I was
thinking of during the brown.
(groans)
The brown.
- [Mark] That's very interesting.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Mark] What advice would
you give to a young person,
young girl, perhaps, who's
reading the work of Jack Kerouac
and into this alternative world
and attracted to it
before she gets into it?
- Well-
- [Mark] And make some of the
moves that you did early on
that are hard to reverse.
- I think that one's
own belief in oneself.
Maintaining your self-confidence
and just being genuine
is the best thing.
If you are yourself in spite of yourself.
As long as you're genuine, you'll be okay.
Learn from your mistakes.
As long as, as you're
learning, you're growing.
And I feel that I,
something, even if it's minute, every day,
something can change, something grows
and as long as that's happening,
then you're living.
Be genuine.
Sometimes that's all there is.
It's all you have.
This life can be so
hard and you can get so down on yourself
and so ground down but
you can always be grateful
for that if you're really,
if you're being true to yourself
and if you're good to yourself
and you're good to other people.
- [Mark] Excellent.
Okay, Rogan.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- You're welcome.
- [Mark] Very interesting talk.
- I told you it was
going to be a good one.
(Mark laughs)
- [Mark] You were right.
- [Rogan] (indistinct)